thank you yes yet in there you have
posed a question that is been important
us latin american has one of the highest
youth unemployment rates in the world
how could latin america increase
opportunities for young when ms alex
kailash ii and i am a specialist in
gerontology and you will be surprised if
i say that one way is first of all to
use the experience of other people so
that they can contribute a solution and
in doing so if we keep all the people in
bright and contribute to society for
every three all the people that are
there fully involved in society you will
open one job opportunity at the bottom
of the age pyramid again so it may sound
to you paradox but the way i'm answering
your questions that let us keep
opportunities for all because we do have
many and people that are unemployed but
also we have mineral the people that are
idle with a lot of part of experience to
contribute and if they are active we are
supporting the economy and create jobs
for you as I expect you are one of the
young people in the channel